I was told that very high over 60 milligrams of melatonin can fight against cancer.
Is that high about effective?
So yes, it's anywhere between 40 and 200 milligrams of melatonin that could be another thing
against cancer.
It's hard to find a melatonin supplement that's that high.
We have one for malady research that's 20 milligrams and they're small capsules so you can
take three of them to get 60.
Both people take anywhere between 60 and 140 milligrams.
I have one person that thinks taking 200 milligrams of melatonin, but average is between
60 and 140.
My doctor is not familiar with bed and bed is all and told me it's not good for the liver.
Since that remark, I have been gun shy, given it to a husband at the beginning, I put it
into shakes, but he's not drinking shakes.
I used to mix it in with water and put it directly in the feeding tube.
My question to your knowledge, have you heard about this doing something to the liver?
You're taking a pack of the bed is all, which is equivalent to what you'd give a 10 pound
dog.
I don't think you have to worry about any liver toxicity.
I find this funny to hear this from a doctor who readily hands out lipitor, like we talked
about before, like it's Easter candy and pressures and gilks people into doing people therapy
that could kill a person.
They say that the amount of bed is all that could give a 10 pound dog, giving to a 150 pound
person is dangerous to your liver.
I'm sorry, I'm going to tell you what's on that.
So if I start the bed is all that is more effective with the whole geotyphus protocol or is it
better taken it alone?
It's better with the whole protocol, but when you're out of feed tube, you have to cut
a middle of the eyes what you can possibly give a person.